dancy no was a senior advisor to Mitt
Romney and Paul Ryan in the 2012
Republican presidential pan campaign
good morning morning charlie we want to
talk about the implications of the new
policy but what does it say about Donald
Trump that he has changed on these very
important issues first of all there's no
real world view when it comes to Donald
Trump's foreign policy whether it was
President Bush President Obama go back
just about every single president since
in the post-world War two ERA you can
ascribe a worldview to them where there
was some predictability there's not one
here what it seems this administration
does is it looks at the problems before
them and says we've got to solve them
and it's not guided by any real sort of
philosophy now in this particular case I
think why there's sort of a a bipartisan
consensus in the foreign policy
community you have Republicans
celebrating what the administration is
doing right now you also have Democrats
who served in the Obama administration
who are praising what he's doing in
Syria the reason you have this consensus
is because he seems to be taking a very
hard line against what is one of the
most perplexing problems for our
geopolitics which is what to do about
Putin and Russia and because he's doing
that a lot of folks are saying you know
we don't care if he is totally uh
pending what he said before we don't
care if he's totally contradicting
himself because we think he's doing the
right thing I mean we're talking about
west wing whiplash
on so many issues major Garrett got to a
lot of them but on Janet Yellen now
saying he respects her wants to keep her
on China right you know no longer
labeling them a currency manipulator
NATO saying no they're not obsolete
anymore does this suggest that the
moderate wing of the White House they
call them globalist Gary Cohen and
Goldman Sachs it's winning out over the
populist Steve Bannon I think there's
that's part of the story there I think
the other part of the story is HR
McMaster in general and secretary mattis
so take Syria that both McMaster and
mattis know the Syria conundrum very
well they've both worked in in previous
military stints remember mattis was head
of Central Command when the Syria
problem started to heat up they both
worked on military plans they had plans
on the shelf during the Obama
administration so their voice here is
very important from what I understand
from folks working in the NSC right
working the administration right now
President Trump is very deferential to
their expertise particularly mattis and
McMaster but again look at the flip on
NATO
so why the flippin NATO NATO was a tool
everybody knows Putin is terrified of
NATO he wants a weak NATO so suddenly if
you view this through the lens of Trump
wants to you know take a harder stance
towards Putin NATO becomes a tool he
wants to do something about North Korea
you know loosening on China on the on
the currency manipulator issue if China
will be helpful on North Korea becomes a
tool these all become tools in this tool
do you think us-russia relations end up
in a meaningfully different place than
they did under President Obama right now
they are heading that way now whether or
not they will stay that way but it
remains to be seen but you already
hearing things for instance hearing
noise that that Putin is wondering
whether or not sticking by Assad is in
his interest if the US is going to take
a hard line against Putin over that
issue suddenly it becomes a liability
Assad during the entire Obama years was
not a liability for Putin suddenly it is
now again if Trump is anything he's
unpredictable so who knows if he will
stick with this but right now this is
becoming a headache for Putin let me ask
you about other intrigue inside the
White House the Washington Post
reporting this morning on Steve Bannon
says that the man not long ago dubbed
the shadow president is struggling to
keep his job
according to 21 of trumps aides
confidence and allies that the post
spoke with thorough reporting very
thorough reporting is there a shake-up
coming I don't think so
I think that Bannon has probably been
you know weakened to some degree but you
know I am from what I'm hearing there's
so much going on right now we just
rattled off all these issues that the
the administration is dealing with the
world is a mess and they're realizing
it's a mess and they're realizing that
there's a big vacuum in the world and if
they don't feel that other bad actors
will I think the last thing the
president wants right now in the midst
of all this chaos
its massive radical personnel changes so
I don't see that happening soon but he
cannot like the idea that Steve Bennett
had been portrayed as the genius at the
White House no I mean there's lots of
reporting that this is this is this made
him crazy he's the star of the show yeah
Dan scener
good to have
here thank you